Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的话题吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. What does it mean to call yourself a psychologist? That is the question we are going to be answering in today's episode of this podcast. And I'm going to be joined by a wonderful friend and colleague, Dr. Tara Quinn-Cherillo, who is a counselling psychologist. And we're going to be answering this question together. I hope you'll find it a really useful, thought-provoking episode. And and as ever if you've got any questions comments or observations on it please do come along and talk to us you know so I'm going to be in the aspiring psychologist community Facebook group come and discuss your thoughts about this episode here,
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客。称自己为“心理学家”意味着什么？这就是我们今天这期播客要回答的问题。我邀请到了一位出色的朋友和同事，咨询心理学家塔拉·奎因-奇里洛博士（Dr. Tara Quinn-Cherillo），我们将共同探讨这个问题。希望这期节目对你有所启发。一如既往，如果你有任何问题、评论或见解，请一定要来和我们交流。我会出现在“有抱负的心理学家社区”Facebook群组中，欢迎来那里讨论你对这期节目的看法。
because I'd love to know what you think. But for now, let me pass over to a very hot Marianne and Tara, as we answer the question what it means to call yourself a psychologist. And I will catch up with you on the other end. I'd like to welcome along our guest today who is Dr. Tara Quinn-Chirillo. Thanks for joining us Tara. You're welcome. So you are a counselling psychologist and also the Conversation Starter Project founder. Yes, yes. Lovely and we first crossed paths I believe via Facebook didn't we through a professionals group that we're both part of but you're also part of the clinical psychologist collective I yeah I asked if you'd like to be part of it and you were on holiday at the time and you absolutely rose to the challenge
因为我很想知道你的想法。现在，让我们把时间交给正处于酷暑中的玛丽安和塔拉，一起探讨“称自己为心理学家”的含义。节目最后我会再回来。欢迎今天的嘉宾塔拉·奎因-奇里洛博士。谢谢你参加节目，塔拉。不客气。你是一位咨询心理学家，也是“对话启动者项目”（Conversation Starter Project）的创始人。是的，没错。太棒了。我们最初是在Facebook的一个专业小组里认识的，对吧？你也是临床心理学家集体（Clinical Psychologist Collective）的一员。是的，我邀请你加入，当时你正在度假，但你欣然接受了挑战。
so thank you so much for being part of that welcome I think I wrote it on my sunbed. It's always useful to have a little overview of you and where you're at. Would you be able to give us a little flavour of of your career to date Tara? So I am a HCPC registered counselling psychologist so I qualified, oh my gosh I sound really old, a very long time ago, over 20 years ago, so I started my training in 1999 and back then psychologists trained in chunks, I did a master's and then a practitioner diploma and then my doctorate later on. So I've worked in mental health, disability, I've also worked with head injury patients as well, all sorts of things. I've worked in the NHS for many years and then set myself up in
非常感谢你参与其中。欢迎你。我想我是在躺椅上写下回复的。了解你的背景和现状总是很有用的。塔拉，你能简单介绍一下你迄今为止的职业生涯吗？我是一名英国健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）注册的咨询心理学家。我获得资格认证的时间……天哪，我听起来真的很老了，那是很久以前的事了，超过20年了。我是在1999年开始接受培训的。那时候心理学家的培训是分阶段的，我先读了硕士，然后是执业文凭，最后才拿到了博士学位。我曾在心理健康、残疾人服务领域工作，也曾与脑损伤患者共事，做过各种各样的工作。我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作多年，然后在大约七八年前开始从事私人执业。
private practice about seven eight years ago I have a real interest in humanitarian and community work as well so I'm involved in a few projects and run one of my own in my own local area to help people connect and feel better and combat loneliness I love that I'm so inspired by your community work it's incredible so we might well hear more about um about your projects um a little bit later but today we thought it would be a good idea to get together to discuss you know what it means to be and for those of you we are we are not recording video today because um we are both melting because we should say for our listeners it's currently 40 degrees and we we are
我对人道主义和社区工作也非常感兴趣，所以我参与了几个项目，并在当地运营着一个自己的项目，旨在帮助人们建立联系、改善心理状态并对抗孤独。我太喜欢这个了，你的社区工作非常鼓舞人心，真是太棒了。我们稍后可能会详细聊聊你的项目。但今天我们觉得聚在一起讨论“成为心理学家”的含义是个好主意。顺便说一下，我们今天没有录制视频，因为我们俩都快热化了。我们得告诉听众，现在气温高达40度，我们……
you know we're not camera ready so I was going to do some inverted commas um but that that's not going to work but um what it means to call yourself a psychologist and why that can be a bit confusing for the general public but also a bit confusing when you're trying to become a psychologist absolutely I think because even as a psychologist sometimes I struggle with who and who isn't allowed to use the title training has changed a lot over the years as well which I think also is something that added into the mix and I guess a really important thing for people to consider is that it's not a protected title so people can use it who have an undergraduate degree in psychology.
我们现在的状态不适合出镜。我本来想用引号表示一下，但那行不通。我们想讨论的是，称自己为“心理学家”意味着什么，为什么这对公众来说可能有点困惑，对于那些正在努力成为心理学家的人来说也同样令人困惑。确实，即使作为一名心理学家，有时我也会纠结谁有资格使用这个头衔。多年来培训体系发生了很大变化，我认为这也增加了复杂性。我想人们需要考虑的一个非常重要的问题是，它不是一个受保护的头衔，所以拥有心理学本科学位的人也可以使用它。
But when we think about what we call a qualified, a psychologist offering mental health service to the public, I guess is a nice way of putting it, needs to have undergone a certain type of training and needs to be registered with the Health and Care Professions Council. And that makes it really easy because you can look us up on that directory. So anybody who is saying that they are a qualified psychologist offering a service to the public, you should be able to look them up on that register. It's free to access and their name will be there. If it's not there, they are not qualified and they are not registered. OK, and there are a number of titles that are regulated by the HCPC, aren't there? There are, yes. there's quite a few which includes clinical psychology, counseling psychology as well. You do
但当我们谈论一名合格的、向公众提供心理健康服务的心理学家时，我认为比较准确的说法是，他们必须接受过特定类型的培训，并需要在健康与护理专业委员会（HCPC）注册。这让事情变得简单，因为你可以在该名录上查询我们。所以，任何声称自己是向公众提供服务的合格心理学家，你都应该能在该名录上查到他们。它是免费访问的，他们的名字会在上面。如果查不到，说明他们没有资格，也没有注册。好的，HCPC监管的头衔有很多，对吧？是的，确实不少，包括临床心理学、咨询心理学等。
there are psychologists who work predominantly in research as well and I guess you know in our discussion today we need to be really clear that we're talking predominantly about people who are offering a therapeutic service to the public so there may be people who are research psychologists that's very different um but we're talking about people that would look up go and see for something like depression or anxiety who are offering you what we call a clinical service really that might be a very nice way of putting it um and those people need to be registered and that is so that people can keep an eye on that we've done the right training that we're continuing to develop our skills and that we're practicing
也有主要从事研究工作的心理学家。我想在今天的讨论中，我们需要明确一点，我们主要讨论的是那些向公众提供治疗服务的人。可能确实有研究型心理学家，那是另一回事。但我们讨论的是那些人们会因为抑郁或焦虑而去寻求帮助的人，也就是提供我们所说的“临床服务”。这些人需要注册，这样公众才能监督我们是否接受了正确的培训，是否在持续提升技能，以及我们是否在……
within a robust ethical framework that's really important so we all do continuing professional development we all have to re-register with the healthcare professionals council and they keep an eye and people can make complaints about services they receive, which is exactly how it should be. So the framework is there to keep you safe and to keep practitioners in line as well. We need that. And that's what makes a good ethical practitioner. But it's just not very clear to the public what those pathways are. Yeah. And I think when you see someone calling themselves a psychologist I think you just assume someone wouldn't be wouldn't have a wouldn't have the gall enough to do that if they weren't actually qualified and so I think lots of people don't look into the qualifications and just look at what people
在稳健的道德框架内执业。这非常重要。所以我们都会进行持续专业发展（CPD），我们都必须向HCPC重新注册，他们会进行监督，人们也可以对所接受的服务进行投诉，这正是应该有的机制。所以这个框架的存在是为了保障你的安全，并约束从业者。我们需要这个。这就是优秀且合乎道德的从业者所具备的素质。但对于公众来说，这些途径确实不太清晰。是的。而且我认为，当你看到有人自称心理学家时，你会觉得如果他们没有真正的资格，应该不会有胆量这么做。所以我认为很多人不会去深究资质，只是看他们如何描述自己。
are describing themselves as and that is is it done to purposefully mislead I don't know and I certainly had the opposite when I was younger that I had massive imposter syndrome and wouldn't want to at all speak outside of my areas of competence it's you know maybe it's admirable that people live in the world where they feel they can do that but it can be really misleading can't it i'm so glad you brought that up because that's the thing that i struggle with so i was on linkedin literally for 10 minutes before this call um and a coach that i know who's now using the title psychologist this week and that's the thing that i struggle with is that people are using the term and it's the ethics of it so I
这是为了故意误导吗？我不知道。我年轻时正好相反，我有严重的冒名顶替综合症，根本不想在自己能力范围之外发言。也许人们觉得自己有能力这样做是值得钦佩的，但这确实可能具有很强的误导性，不是吗？我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为这正是我所纠结的。我在通话前10分钟还在看领英，有一位我认识的教练本周开始使用“心理学家”这个头衔。我纠结的是人们正在使用这个词，这涉及道德问题。
guess legally you can say if you have a psychology degree you can use that title that's always going to be confusing unless that is changed but what I struggle with is people who perhaps haven't got a first degree in psychology so what we call an undergraduate degree and then call themselves psychologists because that's very different and I really struggle with why someone wants to do that because just like you Marianne I sometimes get nervous about am I able to offer things and I've been doing this for 22 years so you know I really do struggle with that and actually on the one hand I think should I admire these people that they are bold and putting themselves out there but then I actually then remember to go back to my original viewpoint which is actually I struggled to see how that was safe and ethical and how we manage risk in those situations. Yeah you raised a really good point about you know who do you complain to if someone isn't registered or regulated or qualified
我想在法律上，如果你有心理学学位，你就可以使用这个头衔，除非法律修改，否则这永远会令人困惑。但我纠结的是那些甚至没有心理学第一学位（即本科学位）的人也自称心理学家，因为那完全是两码事。我真的不明白为什么有人想这样做。就像你一样，玛丽安，我有时会担心自己是否有能力提供某些服务，而我已经从业22年了。所以我真的对此感到困惑。一方面，我想我是否应该钦佩这些人的大胆和勇于展示自己，但随后我回到最初的观点，即我很难看出这如何能保证安全和道德，以及我们如何在这种情况下管理风险。是的，你提出了一个非常好的观点，关于如果某人没有注册、不受监管或没有资格，你该向谁投诉？
and that's not something I considered. Yes yeah so I did try to raise a complaint against somebody recently actually when you didn't have an undergraduate degree and was using the term psychologist to offer under an umbrella of an applied psychologist name, so using counsellor psychologist as a title, but because they're not registered as anybody, there's no one to complain to. So it's almost as if if you are qualified, you're doing the right thing like we are, you're actually more vulnerable because people can go and make a complaint against you, which is absolutely how it can be. But what do we do if we're concerned about people? You can bring it up with them.
这确实是我没考虑过的。是的，我最近确实尝试对某人提出投诉，那个人没有本科学位，却在“应用心理学家”的旗号下使用“心理学家”这个词，比如使用“咨询心理学家”作为头衔。但因为他们没有在任何地方注册，所以根本没人可以投诉。所以，如果你是合格的，像我们一样做正确的事，你反而更脆弱，因为人们可以投诉你，这确实是现状。但如果我们对某些人感到担忧，我们该怎么办？你可以直接和他们沟通。
I'm not sure what else you can do because I know that our professional bodies are not interested in that, which is another issue. And there are different layers, aren't there? I guess we could do several podcasts on this. There are some people that are using logos from certain professional bodies for example on their website so those professional bodies i think have a duty to be monitoring that and to do something about it um but again if people are just using the term um the word psychology is the science of mind and behavior so if you feel that you are supporting people to understand their behavior and make different life
我不确定还能做什么，因为我知道我们的专业机构对此并不感兴趣，这是另一个问题。而且这有不同的层面，对吧？我想我们可以就此做几期播客。有些人会在网站上使用某些专业机构的标志，我认为这些专业机构有责任进行监控并采取行动。但同样，如果人们只是在使用这个词……“心理学”是研究心灵和行为的科学，所以如果你觉得你在支持人们理解自己的行为并做出不同的生活……
choices then technically maybe you feel that you are a psychologist um the other thing i wanted to bring up and it is a tricky subject is that sometimes when we try and bring this up in the media or between professionals on a public platform it can look like we're being very protective over what we do and i don't feel that it's about that it's not about that we don't want people to say they're psychologists because we need to be very special and a very elite group it's about safety and recently that's the only reason that i like to talk about this is who is offering services to the public people that are often vulnerable maybe not be in a position to make a really good informed choice about who
选择，那么从技术上讲，你可能觉得自己是一名心理学家。我想提出的另一件事，这是一个棘手的话题，有时当我们试图在媒体或公共平台上的专业人士之间提出这个问题时，看起来我们好像在过度保护我们的职业。我不觉得是这样，这并不是因为我们不想让别人自称心理学家，也不是因为我们需要显得很特别或是一个精英群体。这是关于安全问题。最近，这是我喜欢谈论这个话题的唯一原因：谁在向公众提供服务？人们往往是脆弱的，可能无法在选择服务对象时做出非常明智的决定。如果你过度焦虑或抑郁，你有多大能力去深入调查一个人并知道……
they're seeing if you're overly anxious or you're depressed how often are you going to be able to be in a position to really look into someone and to know there's a trust element huge trust element someone says they are but they presumably are and that's I guess why it's really important that we speak out and try and help people make more informed choices about who they see yeah I think if you do see certain logos you think that they're credible but actually um let's talk about it it's bps isn't it that we're alluding to that you could be registered with the bps as a graduate member and then you could display their logo yes but if if you were doing that the general public might assume that you were at doctoral
这里存在信任因素，巨大的信任因素。有人说他们是，人们就假设他们是。我想这就是为什么我们必须站出来，帮助人们在选择服务对象时做出更明智的选择。是的，我认为如果你看到某些标志，你会认为他们是可信的。但实际上，让我们谈谈吧，我们指的是英国心理学会（BPS），对吧？你可以作为研究生会员在BPS注册，然后展示他们的标志。是的，但如果你这样做，公众可能会假设你达到了博士水平，因为你不一定非要说明你的会员等级。所以人们使用“注册”这个词，这实际上出现在任何人的文书上。所以当我还是学生时，我就可以注册为学生会员。甚至在我开始培训之前，我就注册了，这很令人兴奋，因为我想获得CPD活动。我想学习。我想获得工作板块，那曾经是在我们那个年代互联网还没普及之前，杂志背后的板块。但我老了。但这里有区别。你可以注册任何组织，但这并不能说明你做了什么……
level because you don't necessarily have to say what level of membership you have so people use the term registered which actually is on anybody's paperwork so when i was a student you could register as a student member so even before i started my training i registered that was very exciting to do because i wanted to get, you know, CPD events. I wanted to learn. I wanted to get the job section, which used to be at the back of the magazine we got in those days before the Internet became a huge thing because I'm that old. But there is a difference. I'm registered with. You could be registered with any organization, but it doesn't tell you much about what you do
以及你能提供什么，你有多安全、多合乎道德。实际上，当你成为一名合格的心理学家时，如果你不想，你甚至不需要在BPS注册。所以没有标志并不一定意味着缺乏资格。但如果有人自称是受保护的头衔之一，比如临床心理学家、法医心理学家、运动与锻炼心理学家或咨询心理学家，那么他们需要向HCPC注册。如果他们没有注册，你可以向HCPC举报他们，让他们停止这种行为。所以有些人很聪明，他们做过研究，知道如何规避……
and what you're able to provide and how safe and ethical you are and actually when you are a qualified psychologist you don't even need to now be registered with the vps if you don't choose to so the absence of a logo isn't necessarily the sign of a lack of qualification but if someone is calling themselves one of the protected titles like clin psych or you know forensic psychologist or you know sport and exercise psychologist counselling psychologist then they need to be registered with with the hcpc and if they are not then you can report them to the hcpc to get that stopped so you know some people are very clever so they have done this research so they know to get that stopped? and that's really confusing for the public now the public are using social media to find people and there's a number of BBC
这让公众感到非常困惑。现在公众通过社交媒体寻找服务，过去几年BBC实际上有几部关于非监管治疗师的纪录片，探讨人们去找谁看病以及如何找到他们。所以途径正在改变。当人们在社交媒体上查看时，你的头衔、你展示自己的方式也可以让你了解你的资质……
documentaries actually over the last couple of years about unregulated therapists in general and who people are going to see and how they're finding them so the route's changing and when people are looking at social media your title, the way that you portray yourself also can give you an indication of how qualified you
但实际上，这可能完全是另一回事，不是吗？是的，考虑到我们的听众是“有抱负的心理学家”，我可以想象，看到那些自称心理学家的人在他们还在努力通过正规、艰苦的途径奋斗时，却赚取了相当可观的收入，这确实令人沮丧。这是一个非常重要的点。我知道当你在谈论做这个播客时，第一步是想：我们需要教育公众。但那段旅程是什么样的呢？像我这样，我的课程是自费的，我必须在医院上夜班才能成为一名稳健、合乎道德的从业者，我必须努力奋斗才能在日常工作中做到最好。有时当我接到转诊时，我甚至会想，其实我不确定这是否适合我，也许更专业的专家应该接手。
are but actually you can do a different story can't it yeah and with our audience being aspiring psychologists i can imagine it's quite disheartening to see people calling themselves psychologists and making you know probably a reasonable income when they're trying to do it you know the actual qualified hard slog route um you know it really disheartening that's such an important point i know when you're talking about doing this podcast you know the kind of first call is to think right we need to educate the public but also what is that journey like you know someone like myself my course was self-funded i had to work night shifts in hospitals to be a robust ethical practitioner and i had to strive
我以此为荣。实际上，当有些人不认为这是一个问题，并且很乐意使用这个词时，这确实会让人感到非常沮丧。这通常是为了获得随之而来的声望。你知道，人们往往不会质疑“心理学家”这个词。是的，我看到了，这确实有一种……我想说“稳健”，这个头衔听起来很稳健。这个人一定知道自己在做什么。
really hard to do my best on a day-to-day basis and there are even sometimes when i take referrals i think actually i'm not sure that's the case for me maybe someone who specializes there a bit more should take that on um and i pride myself on that and actually it can be really frustrating when you've got people who don't see that as an issue who are quite happy to use something it's often the words be clear about the prestige that goes along with that you know quite often people won't question the word psychologist yes and i see them and there is a certain um i guess the word robust, that title sounds quite robust. This person must know what they're doing.
他们一定能处理我的问题。也许我和他们在一起会感到安全。当然，我知道当有病人向我咨询时，他们问心理学家和……的区别，很多人说只是让他们觉得找心理学家很安全。这其中确实有些东西，不是吗？你知道，你把自己标榜为心理学家，这真的很不道德，非常不道德。这让我质疑……
They must be able to manage my problems. Maybe I feel safe with them. And certainly I know when I've had patients inquiring to me, what are the differences between psychologists and, you know, a lot of them have said just make them feel safe seeing a nurse psychologist. There is something there, isn't it? You know that and you're offering yourself out as a psychologist it's really unethical really really unethical and it does make me question
你为什么一开始要进入这个行业？是的，当我回顾我的头衔“临床心理学家”时，它包含了之前经历的一切。那些好日子、坏日子，我得到第一个助理职位的时候，我在病房里感到压力巨大、甚至感到恶心的时候……所有这些，还有我毕业那天，我戴着那顶滑稽的分院帽在教堂里，感到如此自豪，即将走上舞台的那一刻，所有这些都伴随着我。我是临床心理学家，但我经历了多年的磨练。这有点像皇家海军的生活，不是吗？我带来了那份丰富的经验，所有那些不同的……
why are you in that industry in the first place yeah when i when i reflect back on my title clinical psychologist when i use that it's like everything that's gone before me you know the good days bad days the time I got my first assistant post the time I had some real stress in my vibe room was feeling really sick you know all of that and then the day when I graduated and I was wearing my funny little sorting hat um in the in the cathedral feeling so proud about to cross that stage having that moment that all goes with me you know I'm a clinical psychologist but I am years in the making it's a bit like that Royal Navy life but it is isn't it you know and I bring that wealth of experience all of those different
层面都伴随着我。这就是我们作为合格心理学家的独特之处，我们能够将多层面的思考和方法，甚至有时是来自不同职业的多层面经验带入到我们与人们的工作中。人们经常对我说，那些以前看过治疗师的人，“哦，好的，你不一样。这很不同。”你知道，这不仅仅是咨询。咨询当然有它的位置，对吧？但咨询心理学是不同的，因为它是将其应用于临床环境和临床人群。
levels with me and that's what makes us quite unique as qualified psychologists is that we're able to bring multi-layered thinking and approach and even maybe sometimes multi-layered experience from different careers in to what we're doing with people and people have often said to me who've had therapists before oh okay you're, you're different. This is different. You know, it's not just counselling. So counselling absolutely has its place, doesn't it? But counselling psychology is different because it's the application of that to clinical settings and clinical populations.
这确实不同，不是吗？当你和心理学家在一起时，这是一个非常主动的过程。绝对是。而且，这需要很长时间，需要为专家进行深入的构思，观察人类行为动力学，以及它们如何影响心理健康和我们的行为，以及最终是什么导致问题持续存在。正如你所说，心理学家往往不会直接开始培训，他们必须做许多不同的工作，有时还要上夜班。正如你所说，我们所做的所有那些不同的工作，这就是为什么我想……
And it is different, isn't it? It's quite an active process when you're with a psychologist. Absolutely. And, you know, it takes a long time with very in-depth formulations for specialists and looking at human behavioural dynamics and how that may impact mental health and our behaviour and what then ultimately keeps problems going and as you say there is something about quite often psychologists don't go straight into doing their training they have to do many different jobs and sometimes working night shifts and as you say you know all of those different jobs that we've done that's why I wanted
为你的书写我的章节，因为我想人们可能想知道这段旅程是什么样的，以及它如何塑造了你作为一名从业者。所以当有人坐在我面前时，我不仅在运用我的培训，还在运用多年来的性格塑造，以及那些我不想做的工作和夜班，然后第二天还要去听讲座。但这一切都是其中的一部分。我想对我来说，这关乎什么对你个人来说是合适的。我们可能永远无法克服这一点，总会有一些人可能在框架之外，但我认为我们可以尽力教育公众，让他们做出明智的选择。他们可能会根据某人的工作内容决定去看谁，但这与把自己宣传为不是的东西是完全不同的。
to write my section for your book because I thought actually people maybe want to know what the journey is like and how that shapes you as a practitioner so when someone's in front of me I'm drawing on not just my training but years and years and the character building stuff and the jobs I didn't want to do in the night shifts that I really didn't want to do and then go do lectures the next day but it's all part of it and I guess this for me there's something isn't there just about what sits well with you as an individual and we might never be able to overcome that there will always be individuals who might be outside of that framework but I think we can do our best to educate the public so they can make an informed choice they might decide to see someone based on what they do but that's very different than advertising
是的，所以如果你完全了解某人有什么或没有什么资格，并且你相信他们的推荐，你选择做出明智的决定，那完全没问题。我们真的希望这对你有效。这不是吃不到葡萄说葡萄酸，这是为了与公众沟通，了解该寻找什么，以及人们可能并不像他们看起来的那样。对我来说，这归结为风险背景和进行风险评估。我看到的每一个病人，我都在观察风险评估方面什么是有帮助的，什么是没有帮助的。而那些没有经过心理学培训的人，你不能把这视为理所当然。所以那些通过小组……的问题……
yourself as something you are not yeah so if you're fully aware what qualifications someone has or haven't got and you believe their testimonials and you're choosing to make that as an informed decision absolutely fine and we really hope that works well for you this is not a case of sour grapes this is a case of communicating to the public um you know what to look for and that people may not be as they seem and it's that for me it comes down to risk background and doing risk assessments every patient i see i'm looking at what's helping and what's not helping in terms of risk assessment. And people who have not gone through psychology training, you cannot take that as given. So somebody who's coming through groups, and the problem
非监管和不合格的心理学家的问题在于，他们可能在运营小组。正如我之前所说，治疗模式已经改变，人们在运营WhatsApp心理健康小组和Facebook小组。当有人被遗漏时会发生什么？因为他们没有那种背景，他们没有风险评估的能力，或者他们没有能力思考他们甚至该如何做。这对我来说是真正让我感到不安的地方，因为我们……无论我们做什么，无论是社区工作，对我来说，无论是社区工作还是付费客户工作，都是完全相同的框架。这是关于……
with unregulated and unqualified psychologists is that they can be running groups. And because I was saying before, the kind of modalities, treatment modalities have changed people are running whatsapp mental health groups and running facebook groups is that what happens when someone gets missed because they don't have that background they don't have that ability to risk assist or they don't have the ability to think about how they even would and that for me is something that really sets up on his path because our you know we will always have a good robust framework around anything we do, whether it's community work, for me whether it's community work, or paid client work, it's exactly the same framework it's about.
归根结底，保障我的病人和客户的安全，同时支持他们解决问题。对我来说，这就是我们的区别所在。是的，绝对是。如果有人不需要在风险框架下被观察，那么他们当然可以在其他地方被观察。这是一种下沉到最合适的服务的做法。但要稳健，要对人们诚实。所以有时人们会来找我，我会说，我其实不认为你需要我，你知道，我认为……
At the end of the day, keeping my patients safe, my clients safe, as well as supporting them in their problems. And to me that's what differentiates us. Yeah, absolutely. And if someone doesn't need to be seen with a risk framework then absolutely they can be seen elsewhere you know it's stepping down to the most appropriate service um but it's being robot you know and being honest with people about that so sometimes come people will come to me and i'm like i don't actually think you need me you know i think
我可能比你需要花的钱要多。但他们仍然说，好吧，我想见你，因为我知道你，或者我相信你能帮助我。我说，好吧，我可以。但要诚实，关于你能提供什么，你擅长什么。有时还有其他选择。绝对的，让我们谈谈钱。在某些类型的治疗师、咨询师、心理学家、教练之间，薪酬有巨大的差异。对公众来说，这一定非常令人困惑，而且我有时想象，如果你正在与抑郁或焦虑等问题作斗争，这会非常让人不知所措。所以有些人去看治疗师或教练，因为他们正在寻求某种生活改变，或者与那些处于稍微更危险或更脆弱境地的人寻求的东西略有不同。
um i may be more money than you need to spend, actually. But they're still saying, well, I want to see you because I know of you or I believe that you can help me. And I say, well, I can. But it's being honest, isn't it, about, you know, what you can offer, what you're good at. And there are other options available there sometimes as well. Absolutely you know let's talk money there's a huge difference in pay between certain types of therapists counselors psychologists coaches and to the public that must be really confusing and i imagine at times very overwhelming if you are struggling with something like depression or anxiety for example so some people go to therapy or go to coaches because they're looking for kind of life changes or slightly different things than those that might be in a slightly more risky or more vulnerable situation
所以你怎么知道区别是什么？心理学家通常比其他治疗师和咨询师稍微贵一点，在大多数情况下。这是关于教育公众为什么会这样。我想如果有人为了多赚钱而使用这个头衔，那真的很不道德，这让我非常反感。是的，我听到了，我听到了。我们可能会对此抱怨很久，但这并不是这期节目的功能。这不是一期“吃不到葡萄说葡萄酸”的节目，这是一期信息分享节目，也是对你和你重要工作的概述。你能告诉我们一点关于你的“对话启动者项目”以及你是如何开始它的吗？我的项目是一个非常小的社区项目，旨在帮助人们在疫情后建立联系并管理……
so how do you know what are the differences and psychologists are usually slightly more expensive than other therapists and counselors for the most part and it's kind of educating the public as to why and i guess there's something there isn't it if someone's using a title with the kind of aim of getting paid more money that's really unethical you know doesn't sit well with me at all yeah I hear you I hear you um we could probably moan on about this for ages but this isn't it's not the function it's not a sour grapes um episode it's an information episode and an overview of you and your important work could you tell us a little bit about your conversation starter project and how you got it started so my project was a really i would say is was a really small community project um to help people connect and manage
情绪健康。但实际上，它现在有更广泛的职能。这个想法是，它是一个免费的社区资源，18岁以上的成年人可以来这里，在自然中行走。我们知道，从神经科学的角度来看，我们在自然中行走和交谈时，处理情绪的方式非常不同……
emotional well-being after the pandemic um but actually it has a wider remit now so the idea is that it's a free community resource where adults over 18 can come, walk in nature, so we walk in local parks where we know, from a neuroscience perspective, we process the emotions much differently, or much more different, a little bit of that bit, much more different when you are walking and talking in nature.
但这对于参与者来说是一个非常稳健的框架，有一个非常简单的模型。所以有很多风险评估，有一个非常稳健的框架，有一个非常简单的模型，所以有很多风险评估，有一个保障框架，这样每个人都可以来并获得非常安全的体验。但对用户来说它是免费的，你出现，在不同的时间和不同的地点有不同的步行活动。你出现，你交谈，没有格式，你不必谈论特定的主题，它就是有效。所以我们已经进行了一年，它变得越来越大。我们的想法是，我们希望在越来越多的地方复制这个模型，并培训人们能够交付这个模型。再次强调，我致力于减少……
But it's a really robust framework with a very simple model for the attendees. So there's a lot of risk assessment, there's a really robust framework with a very simple model for the attendees so there's a lot of risk assessment there's a safeguarding framework in place so that everyone can come and have a really safe experience but to the user it's free you turn up you have different walks at different times and different localities you turn up you talk there's no format you don't have to talk about a specific topic and it just works so we've been going a year and it's just getting bigger and bigger and the idea is we'd like to replicate the model across more and more localities and train people up to be able to deliver the model and again i'm about reducing
障碍和污名。所以有时如果我们知道我们必须去某个地方并且必须准时到达，那可能是一个障碍，特别是如果你有焦虑症。所以你可以迟到，你不必准时。我们走同一条路线，所以你可以随时加入我们，随时离开。所以它适合你正在做的其他事情。所以它是人们一周的锚点，它解决了孤独感。我们已经让人们降低了焦虑率，降低了抑郁率，也降低了社交焦虑率。在经历了所有的封锁和不知道如何与人交谈之后，这真是一件很棒的事情。参与其中让我感觉很好。我现在有一个很棒的志愿者团队，他们每周多次免费贡献自己的时间……
barriers and stigma so sometimes if we know we've got to go somewhere and be there exactly on time that can be a barrier especially if you have anxiety so you can come late you don't have to come on time we walk the same route so you can join us whenever you can leave whenever so it fits in with the other things you're doing so it's an anchor for the week for people it tackles loneliness we've already had people reduce rates of anxiety reduce rates of depression you know reduce rates of social anxiety as well off the back of all those lockdowns and not knowing how to talk to people so it's a really lovely thing to be involved in it makes me feel good being able to do that i have a wonderful team of volunteers now which is just incredible who give their time for free every single week multiple times a week
希望它能继续下去。你知道，我可以通过社区工作接触到更多的人，这不仅仅是我的临床工作，这就是我做它的原因。我喜欢这个，它太鼓舞人心了。我知道当你刚开始的时候，我不记得是周三的10点还是11点，你都会在那里，即使下着倾盆大雨，你也会说：“好吧，我现在得走了，我要出发了。”无论风雨，无论热浪，我们都在那里。我认为这就是人们喜欢的。人们对小组有主人翁意识。所以每个来的人，你不必每周都来，这也是为什么……
um and hopefully it'll continue you know i can reach more people doing community work as well it's just my clinic work and that's why i do it I love that it's so inspiring and I know when you first started I can't remember if it was 10 o'clock or 11 o'clock on a Wednesday but you'd be there and we'd be pouring with rain and you're like all right I've got to go now I'm off out and come rain come shine come whatever heat waves, we are there. And I think that's what people like. People take ownership of the group. So every person that comes along, you don't have to come every week, which is also why
它有效的原因。你需要在需要的时候来。在大多数情况下，人们来得很频繁，但有些人只是偶尔参与。有些人也把它作为其他事情的基础。所以我们现在有了与当地机构的正式途径，这太棒了。所以有时这有助于人们在休假期间重返工作岗位。身体健康问题有时也是如此，因为温和的步行可以帮助那些从各种疾病中恢复的人。这真的很好，我从来没有觉得这是一种苦差事，这一定说明了什么。
it works. You come when you need it. For the most part, people come quite regularly, but some people just dip in and out. Some people use it as a foundation to other things as well. So we have the formal pathways now with local agencies which is fantastic um so sometimes that helps people get back into work while they're off work physical health issues as well sometimes because the walking gentle walking can help people who are recovering from all sorts of things um and it's just really lovely to do it's really yeah I never walk away feeling like it's a chore and that has to be something.
哦，那太珍贵了，不是吗？当你觉得你是在……我会说你是免费做的，但你一直都是这样。但它感觉既是在给予他人，也是在给予你自己。这就是你知道你在做正确事情的时候。绝对的。对他人的同情心被证明有助于我们个人的幸福。所以，你投入时间思考他人以及小组如何发展，实际上对我的幸福感也很有帮助。是的，太棒了，塔拉。很高兴……
Oh, that's golden, isn't it? When you feel like you're, you know, I'd say you're doing it for free, but you have been anyway, you know. But, you know, it feels like it's giving to you as well as, you know, giving to others. That's where you know that you're doing something good. Absolutely. Compassion for others is evidence-based to help our individual well-being. Sobeing so you know the time that i invest in thinking about others and how the group can develop is actually really good for my well-being as well yeah yeah brilliant tara it's been such a pleasure
和你交谈。那么让我们回顾一下：人们担心有人可能声称自己不是他们所说的那样。有什么好的第一步，有什么好的方法来调查他们的资格吗？我经常在领英上看看他们的教育部分，这是个好主意吗？这取决于平台，有很多不同的平台。我最近写了一篇关于这个的博客。我所说的一件事是，通常要进行那些对话。一个稳健、合乎道德的从业者不会介意与你讨论他们的资格，他们甚至应该为你指路。我向我所有的病人展示：我在这里，去查我吧。你知道，我在这里，如果你对……
speaking with you um and let's just recap then so people are concerned that somebody is perhaps claiming to be something that they're not um is there a good first step a good way of investigating what their qualifications might be i often have a little look on linkedin to see what's in their education section is that a good idea so it depends there's lots of different platforms so i wrote a blog on this recently actually so one of the things i've said is often you know have those conversations a robust ethical practitioner will not mind discussing their qualifications with you and they should even signpost you i show all my patients here i am go look me up you know this is where i am this is where you go if you have an issue
他们所做的事情有疑问，这就是你去的地方。所以，在HCPC网站上查他们，问他们的资格是什么，他们的专业机构是谁。即使只是问这个问题，有时也会给你一个巨大的信号，预示着接下来会发生什么。并与他们谈论你的担忧。对我来说，我总是认为有时需要进行困难的对话，因为这关系到你和你的幸福，而且你正在支付你的钱。所以我们在这里谈论的是在私人诊所工作的从业者。你正在支付你的钱去看他们。你有权知道你的学生是年轻的，谁是合乎道德的。但去看看吧。拥有第一学位的心理学家可以自称心理学家，但这与成为一名合格的、……
with what they do um so look them up on the HCPC website, ask them what their qualifications are, who's their professional body, even just asking that question will sometimes give you a huge indicator of what's coming next and talk to them about your concerns and to me I always think sometimes difficult conversations are needed because it comes to you and your well-being and you're passing your money. So we're talking about practitioners who are working in private factories here. You are part of your money to see them. You have a right to know your students are young, who's ethical. But have a look. A psychologist who has a first degree can call themselves a psychologist, but that's very different from being a qualified and
受监管的、向公众提供心理健康服务的心理学家是完全不同的。所以他们应该拥有博士水平的资格。我们使用这个术语或同等学历。所以一些从业时间很长的人会拥有硕士学位，然后是心理学文凭，但他们会为你解释这一点。你不必非要去查那个，他们会谈论……如果他们不想谈论它，对我来说这总是一个巨大的危险信号。是的，绝对是。非常感谢你的时间。如果人们想和你联系，有什么好的方法吗？我在Twitter上，我是@Chirillo……
regulated psychologist off in the mental health service to the public so they should have doctoral level qualifications we use the term or equivalent so some people who've been practicing quite a long time will have a master's degree and then a diploma in psychology but they will talk you through that you don't have to go and look that up they will talk you know and if they don't want to talk about it that to me is always a big red flag yeah absolutely thank you so much for your time um is there a good way for people to be able to connect with you if they should like to i'm on twitter so i'm at chirillo
Doctor。我在www.drtara.co.uk。你能帮我们拼写一下我们在Twitter上怎么找你吗，塔拉？我知道。是@Chirillo，大写C-I-R-I-L-L-O，然后是大写D，小写r。太好了。非常感谢。谢谢你今天能来，尽管有40度的高温。你现在可以去喝杯冰饮休息一下了。我要融化了。
doctor um and i am on www.drtara.co.uk could you help us spell could you help us spell how we look for you on Twitter, if that's okay, Tara? I know. So it's at Chirillo, capital C-I-R-I-L-L-O, and then capital D, lowercase r. Lovely. Thank you very much. Thank you for coming along today, despite the 40-degree heat. You may now go and recline with an icy drink. I'm going to get a melt.
是的。谢谢你加入我，塔拉。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢大家的收听。希望你觉得这是一次非常有益、有趣且引人入胜的收听体验。塔拉对我来说确实是一个启发。你对使用“心理学家”这个词有什么看法？你认为它应该受到保护吗？你是否遇到过那些在没有必要背景支持的情况下使用这个头衔的人？你有什么想法？欢迎来Facebook群组“有抱负的心理学家社区与玛丽安·特伦特博士”和我讨论这个问题。那里有很多好东西，而且完全免费加入。所以来吧，好吗？同时，非常感谢你的收听。
Yes. Thank you for joining me tara thank you thank you thank you for listening i hope you found it a really useful interesting engaging listen tara is certainly a bit of an inspiration for me what do you think about using the term psychologist do Do you think it should be protected? Have you stumbled across people who are using the title without possibly the necessary backing behind them? What are your thoughts? Do come and discuss this with me over on the Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. That is where lots of good stuff happens and it's totally free to join. So come and do that, won't you? In the meantime, thank you so much for listening.
是的。谢谢你加入我，塔拉。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你们的收听。我希望你们觉得这是一次非常有用、有趣且引人入胜的收听体验。塔拉对我来说确实是一种启发。你对使用“心理学家”这个词有什么看法？你认为它应该受到保护吗？你是否遇到过在没有必要背景支持的情况下使用这个头衔的人？你有什么想法？欢迎来到Facebook群组“有抱负的心理学家社区（Aspiring Psychologist Community）”与我一起讨论，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。那里有很多好东西，而且完全免费加入。所以，来加入我们吧，好吗？在此期间，非常感谢你们的收听。
And I'm looking forward to connecting with you again very soon. The next episode of the podcast will be available for you from 6am on Monday, but yeah, it will be here for you whenever you're ready. Please do subscribe on your chosen podcast platform. And if you're watching on YouTube, subscribe there too. If you're listening on Apple, please do take a moment to rate and review. It really is appreciated. Thank you for being part of my world and I'll catch up with you very soon. Bye. Thank you. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Boom. If you're looking to become a psychologist,
我非常期待很快能再次与你交流。下一期播客将于周一早上6点发布，当然，无论你何时准备好，它都会在这里等你。请在你选择的播客平台上订阅。如果你是在YouTube上观看，也请订阅。如果你是在Apple上收听，请花点时间评分和评论。这真的非常感谢。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快再见。再见。谢谢。这是《临床心理学家合集》。砰。如果你想成为一名心理学家，
then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd
那就让这成为你的指南吧。有这个播客陪伴，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣，各种通往目标的途径之多让我感到惊讶，成为心理学家并没有所谓的完美路径，这让我充满信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我
definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下了。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。